across the continent extreme weather
caused by climate changes upending
people's lives forcing them to flee
their homes and pushing Millions into
hunger and starvation there are Grim new
figures from the World Meteorological
organization they say Africa is warming
faster than any other place in the world
and with that agricultural productivity
is declining the rise in sea levels is
increasing along the African Coastline
at a higher rate than the global average
threatening low-lying coastal cities and
extreme weather events like floods and
droughts are increasing in frequency and
intensity killing thousands of people
large swathes of Africa are already
experiencing acute drought and one of
the worst affected countries right now
is Madagascar where the rains have
failed for years our correspondent
Adrian Krish visited the above region
massive watsaga used to be a farmer now
all she is able to harvest our cactus
leaves a rentless drought has left large
parts of Southern Madagascar dry and
unproductive and it has left people like
Mercy in a precarious situation
she now relies on turning cactus leaves
into cattle feet to survive since the
rains stopped a life has been turned on
its head
we left the village because of the
drought it's very difficult to find
water there there was no Harvest so we
had to sell all our belongings
many others are suffering the same fate
as Mercy she lives alongside them in
this informal camp in the town of Ambu
vombe Trader damiheri salal opened the
camp when he saw how many people had
nowhere to go after being forced to
leave their Villages
this old man lying here he used to have
a 120 head of cattle he was a rich man
but over the years he had to sell
everything he owned
and when the people have nothing to eat
they end up just lying here like this
[Music]
here in the region they call it the
hunger people got used to not having
enough food going to bed hungry it is
incredible how they managed to adapt to
this hostile environment but of course
it comes at a price
in charge of the malnutrition unit for
children at the hospital in Abu Bombay
she says many children here are
chronically ill last month two children
came too late and died
this little girl is one of the five she
is currently treating
this baby is 17 months old
her arm circumference is very low it's
in the red part
98 millimeters
normally it should be 130 for her age
she still can't stand
normally at this age children already
run she can't even stand up
no
we don't have good food at home
sometimes we mix the nutrition Aid that
ngos give us with cassava
and we cook the cassava with a lot of
water if I have some money I buy sweet
potatoes
back at the camp damihari salal says he
tries to help here and there by buying
medicine and collecting donations he
believes mainly climate change is to
blame for the situation but he also says
corruption by NGO staff and government
incompetence are making matters worse
for decades the government fails to
invest in the region the cycle of
poverty gets worse as rainfall gets less
it is definitely going to be very
difficult to stop this crisis
unless the aid organizations clean up
their Acts
and it will also be difficult if the
government doesn't see what's really
happening on the ground to take the
right measures
we need a Hands-On approach to bring
this situation to an end
Erman
as she prepares the first and only meal
of the day for her family massive wat
Saga asks herself why this is happening
I don't know why the rain doesn't fall
it may be because of because of humans
we don't love each other maybe that's
why the rain has stopped falling or
because strangers did something to
prevent the rain I don't know
some greens and two cups of rice that's
all the family of 14 can afford for
today yet they still offer their
neighbors to join trying to help
Madagascar and to talk more about this I
am joined by Mohammed abdika he is
director for East Africa and the Horn of
Africa at the un's International
Organization for migration it's good to
have you on the program thank you so
much for being here Mr aptica let's
begin by talking about the migration in
Africa that is being caused by climate
change just what is the scale of this
challenge thank you for having me here
today first we need to talk about
climate change we can no longer ignore
the issue of displacement mobility and
migration and we never used to talk
about that and right now we bring that
issue of mobility in migration that is
becoming key for us a good example is in
Somalia where today we have over 1.3
million people displaced because of slow
induced climate migration 1.3 million
people at the same time you have close
to 7.8 million people in need of food
assistance and if we don't act very
quickly we have over 288
thousand people who are an acute food
insecurity who might die because of lack
of food that just gives you an example
of the scale in Somalia but if you look
at the region itself over 36.1 million
people in little assistance because of
slow onset climate emerges that we're
dealing with today
well I mean these these numbers are
astonishing and you talked about action
and when I get to that point um in a
short moment but let's talk about the
patterns if we can when people do move
how do they move it and where are they
likely to go I think right now what's
happened you see a lot of rural urban
migration I can use Somali as a case
study where we're seeing a large number
of somalis moving away from rural areas
to the capital city or to the cities
within the country itself if you talk
about baido at the Southwest stage you
have hundreds of thousands of somalis
who've also run away from al-shabab held
areas it's an extremist group they run
from there now they're going to buy
though are looking for assistance and we
have over 10 000 for example arrived
last week alone 10 000 people asking for
assistance whether you when and
humanitarian partners are providing food
shelter Health non-food items for them
people to deal with this but that is
just in Somalia you have some of them in
Burundi you have the rising Waters of
Lake Tanganyika which is displacing
hundreds of boron deals themselves you
go to South Sudan there's a whole city
called Bento underwater the last seven
months because of climate change
Mr abdica um here in Europe uh the focus
is on the migrants who who take the
route uh of crossing the Mediterranean
many have died doing so but in Eastern
Africa where you work there are also
dangerous routes that people are taking
can you tell us more about that um the
biggest road the biggest Maritime route
in the world is called the Eastern Road
the biggest Maritime route in the world
everybody talks about Libya
Mediterranean to Europe that's right
Beverly talks about Mexico U.S border
but when you talk about the Eastern
Europe you talk about the largest
Maritime migration route in the world
from the Horn of Africa through Somalia
Djibouti the Red Sea to Yemen which is a
country in Conflict to Saudi Arabia
every year we have a close to 150 000
people 150 000 people who cross through
these countries in deserts been smuggled
and trafficked going into Yemen conflict
Zone and going into Saudi Arabia at the
same time we have Saudi Arabia deporting
a large number of these migrants back to
home countries a good example is in
Ethiopia they've deported the last seven
months a hundred and three thousand
Ethiopians back to Ethiopia itself
um a lot of those people on the Move
would classify as being climate change
refugees people who've been displaced
because of climate change
um generally is this issue being given
enough attention that is is the
International Community committing
enough money to helping people in this
desperate position you've you've told us
some really astonishing numbers the what
we've come up with what we call the
migrant response plan for Horn of Africa
and Yemen it's appealing for about close
to 100 million dollars to support these
migrants in Djibouti in Yemen
in Somalia in Ethiopia itself we are
getting some support not as much as we
wanted to get but it's not as much
support as we would like to see and we
always appeal to our development
partners and donors to increase that
support we've seen the smuggling the
trafficking we've seen the economic
impact this has on these migrants and
we're seeing a very different Trend
which is a feminization of migration
before it used to be men on the move
trying to feed their families but now
we're seeing more and more women and
girls on the move as well and that is
what is worrying us more because of the
trafficking the abuse the gender-based
violence they go through on the end
route to their migration those trying to
reach mostly Saudi Arabia that's where
they want to go that's where we have the
domestic workers it's irregular migrants
themselves and that has an impact but
also it's not just climate induced
migration what we have is very much an
economic reason we ask them all the time
why are you on the move and all of them
tell us I have no job it's poverty it's
a lack of economic opportunities in the
region and people on the Move well Mr
abdica we could really go on for a lot
longer but I think we we can leave it
here right now that is Mohammed abdica
from the international organization of
migration thank you sir thank you thank
you for having me